i'm a superhero now so that's normal
it's definitely not every day that an
mcu superfan ends up starring in a
marvel series especially one that has
zero professional acting experience the
miss marvel show has it all a young
bright-eyed star visuals to die for and
a whole lot of marvel love fans of the
mcu are you ready for this my heart is
very full number one this has got to be
a scam or is it this was just something
that felt so faded that i had to try
when aman valani was forwarded a
whatsapp message from her aunt she was
pretty sure she was being punked super
sketchy i don't know what casting calls
look like but valani didn't let the fact
that it wasn't the most legit seeming
message stop her from taking a chance i
sent him my self tape at like 3 am
wasn't gonna do it next thing she knew
she got a call from marvel studios
requesting she fly to la to audition and
i was like i have a math test but no
worries she knew where her priorities
were and she lived a real life dream
going to the marvel studios it's the
coolest feeling ever and i wanted to
take full advantage of being there then
the dream got interrupted when the
pandemic hit and the road to marvel
became a bit more complicated then my
next screen test got cancelled after
waiting for a few months iman was
getting anxious since she also had some
decisions to make about college and time
was running out they asked for another
screen test over zoom and that was the
last audition she did for marvel
number two this doesn't happen every day
it was the last day school we were going
to get burritos and then this happened
what made it even more intense was the
fact that she hadn't told her friends
about the fact that she auditioned but
she could not keep her cool when she
opened up the zoom call to kevin feige's
face you've done amazing work and we'd
be honored if you would play a kamala
khan for us in the miss marvel show and
it was unanimous decision and we know
how the rest of the story goes
number three she may be new to the mcu
but she wasn't shy about taking what she
wanted i stole a lot from our show we're
not just talking about swiping an item
here and there or keeping a costume
piece this was a fully planned affair my
assistant and i went around the entire
stage and were taking photos of
everything i wanted to steal and on the
last day i was saying bye to people and
she was putting things in bags and we
shipped everything home laurel marsden
was very into her costume as well and
then they put on the boots and i was
like
i can't keep these right it was a hard
no but not for long they left them in my
trailer and i still have the boots i
wear them all the time number four miss
marvel and captain marvel make a winning
combo it's a very similar relationship
to kamala and carol danvers and the
comics and then like mean bree in real
life brie larson reached out to the
newest member of the marvel fam to hang
out on facetime immediately becoming her
mentor and guiding her through
navigating the mcu and what comes along
with being a superhero if valani was
struggling she could shoot a text and
her mentor would just hop on a call with
her
how to keep your cool when it's so
overwhelming you know around you number
five if you're gonna be a superhero you
gotta do some stunts i got this right
iman valani may be new but she took on
many of her own stunts showing off her
best battle moves and pulling off all
sorts of wire work
number six
this was a definite upgrade from the
costume she made herself for halloween
many years ago it's just so hard to like
be like yeah you're here mark him to
marvel that's my slogan oh yeah the
homemade costume was real but when she
suited up for the first time i could
have stopped staring at myself and
neither could anyone else there were so
many people who wanted to be in the room
when we were trying on the costume for
the first time because everyone was so
giddy and excited but she quickly
discovered one of the biggest downsides
of the mcu life and i was like i have to
go to the bathroom and now i need help
number seven avengers who work out
together stay together miss marvel was
filming in atlanta next door to the loki
series and no way home so superheroes
were regularly bumping into each other
right before work and then there's this
guy doing like crazy box jumps and how
did they fare with the mischievous
workout iman was fine i was wheezing
number eight she was just a marvel lover
living her marvel dream and this was the
best dream of all episode one features
the avenger con and it also happened to
be one of the last scenes shot in studio
in atlanta iman valani was walking into
this set blind since the production team
didn't allow her to see the set until
she got there to film they wanted me to
have a genuine reaction and it was oh so
worth it i just remember just not being
able to speak it was it was like
marvel vomit it's what i want my bedroom
to look like number nine this one took
some work shopping i've been practicing
my superhero pose for for like years
long before this part a lot of the poses
we see in the series are familiar and
that was part of the fun we wanted to
like have a lot of black widow poses and
like cool captain marvel poses one of
the most fun aspects of being a
superhero would definitely be being
excited that you're a superhero and this
team did not hold back this is like the
only show where we can like really be
cheesy and and embrace the the you know
how exciting it would be if any fan
became a superhero number 10 most marvel
rehearsals don't involve board games but
that didn't mean they couldn't and our
rehearsal was just playing settlers of
catan together the team suggested iman
and matt have a solo rehearsal with
their director mira menon but it became
more of a bonding session and i remember
thinking this girl's awesome playing the
game with valani was very telling of
what it would be like to work together
on set i remember at one point i did
something wrong i put a bridge where i
wasn't supposed to bridge and iman was
like you you can't do that number 11 was
this character based on iman valani it's
being myself on a larger scale before
filming the producers and directors did
a deep dive into who aman valani was
what her school life was like who she
had crushes on what her interests were
essentially hand painting this character
to suit the actress playing her it just
made it really easy for me to kind of
slip into the character as well to be
fair it wasn't too much of a stretch she
was pakistani and she was muslim and a
superhero fanatic i was a pakistani
muslim superhero fanatic like that's
just insane the fact that she knew the
character from the comics inside and out
helped too but at the end of the day she
really was perfect for the role yeah i
literally put my entire self into the
show number 12 who doesn't love a good
improv when mira menon was in the
directing chair she wanted to have a
free and loose set where the actors felt
able to make the characters their own
and really dig into the vibes give them
some loose ends to play with whenever
filming before and after a written scene
menin told the actors to have at it and
improvise their way through always
making sure to include the lines in the
script as well of course
number 13 bringing authenticity to the
forefront was key for this project i
mean it was authenticity all around and
they got it kamala's family dynamics
reflected the culture she's yet very
very typical south asian mother
protective and loving and kind but also
can like kick a little bit of butt when
she needs to and on screen we get to see
the mosque that kamala khan goes to
alongside multiple other cultural
aspects marking special importance since
all of that does become part of khan's
journey i just put a lot of my real life
into into kamala's character and making
her as authentic as possible number 14
those relationships on screen translate
off-screen we didn't have to deal with
any drama you can't fake chemistry like
what we see in the show the actors all
spent endless amounts of time together
creating real-life bonds that were
shockingly strong until the point that
the team realized this production fam
was the real deal
number 15. who doesn't love an
international trip part of the reason
the cast bonded so well was because they
got to travel the world together filming
a marvel movie and then hanging out in
london england is not a bad deal at all
iman valani never stopped working it
seems even creating a video of her
adventures hitting up london with the
cast during their time off and remember
when she wasn't doing this she was
bringing kamala khan to the screen real
life superhero much
miss marvel is a marvel there's no doubt
about that and this is just the
beginning since she's already filmed
alongside brie larson for the marvels
film velani has been dreaming up collabs
with other mcu characters who would you
want to see her share the screen with
you